so we've been covering what's going on
in Iran and part of that story includes
that yesterday Donald Trump casually
threatened war crimes against Iran on
Twitter threatening Iranian cultural
sites as targets which is a war crime
per the Geneva Convention it's very cut
and dry there's really no ambiguity
about that the question is are the
threats going to become actual orders
and if they become orders what is the
Pentagon what is the military actually
going to do we have some good news if we
can believe it and the believability of
it is something we'll talk about in a
second and the good news is that the
Pentagon immediately said no we are not
going to commit Donald Trump's war
crimes Secretary of Defense mark Esper
admitted yesterday I mean he didn't even
try to deny that targeting Iranian
cultural sites if they are not otherwise
military targets targets of military
value crazy world we live in right if
there is not a standalone military value
to the cultural sites it would be a war
crime and that they would not do it and
this puts mark espera and the Pentagon
directly opposite Trump who insists that
these are legitimate targets and
actually double down on the war crime
threat on Air Force One when asked about
is completely unhinged tweets the
Secretary of Defense Marv Gasper said
quote we will follow the laws of armed
conflict now for like a split second I
kind of felt bad for a second for the
people that have to deal with Donald
Trump and clean up his messes and then I
remembered hey choosing you can choose
whatever job you want they can quit at
any time and then I didn't feel bad for
them anymore but military leaders are in
a position where they have to balance
the law and reality and empiricism with
what Donald Trump wants and what Donald
Trump tweets and Donald Trump often
loses it when he does not get what he
wants Donald Trump threatening war
crimes on Twitter appears to be
disturbing not just international allies
which we talked about yesterday but it's
disturbing even our own military and our
Pentagon and the Secretary of Defense so
I have a few thoughts on this number one
if
indeed the Pentagon is honest in what
they say like if we can trust mark Esper
is telling the truth when he says we're
not going to do it these are war crimes
then that's good but can we believe mark
Esper are they just saying this because
historically the United States doesn't
announce one way or the other when its
military is going to be committing war
crimes we often find out later many
times thanks to investigative journalism
document leaks sometimes FOIA requests
are part of it so this is sort of
uncharted territory where in advance the
president is saying here's an idea let's
commit some war crimes I have a list of
war crimes targets that I would like to
see targeted and then the Secretary of
Defense says no those would be war
crimes we're not going to do it this is
a very backwards way in which this
normally happens but it's conceivable
that getting this out into the open
ahead of time actually makes it less
likely by shining a spotlight on it that
it eventually happens now to keep going
with this if Mark espera is telling the
truth and he can be believed that the
Pentagon the military will not be
committing the war crimes that Donald
from threatened is Mark espers job safe
because we've seen that when a Trump
administration official publicly
contradicts the word of Trump very often
they end up resigning force resignations
and Donald Trump pulls in someone who is
much more willing to do his bidding or
at least shut the hell up about it and
not make it clear that they disagree
with Donald Trump number three
think about how insane things are today
that it is newsworthy that the Pentagon
is ruling out war crimes preemptively as
suggested by the president on Twitter
this is the reality this is a headline
today in 2020 number four the fact that
Donald Trump even threatened these war
crimes is still disgraceful and
potentially an escalating action and
Donald Trump is quickly moving from
being an international laughingstock to
being an international terror and number
five let's not excuse the Republican
Party
large we're going to talk later in the
show about how 20 people or even 14
people in the Senate and cabinet
respectively could put an end to the
worldwide fiasco that is Donald Trump
we'll get to that later not a single
Republican member of the House or Senate
have just said I condemn Donald Trump
casually threatening war crimes on
Twitter not a single one not one
Republican and that's part of why we're
in serious trouble that's part of why
this guy might get himself reelected now
to get back to the war crimes for a
moment what will happen if Donald Trump
gives the order does Marquez per se no
do the general say no in the United
States military orders are only
considered valid if they are legal if
they adhere to the United to the Uniform
Code of Military Justice the UCMJ that's
a separate branch of legal code and all
US military personnel are under oath to
follow that there's also the LOA see the
law of armed conflict
there's the Geneva Conventions and
according to international humanitarian
law and I think with many trumpets if
you say to them international
humanitarian law they just laugh right I
mean they don't care about that
according to international humanitarian
law officers are not to be punished if
they refuse to carry out orders that are
known or suspected to be illegal an
order to intentionally target cultural
sites and cultural objects and locations
lacking military value would absolutely
fall under illegal under that umbrella I
don't know what we would expect to
happen technically illegal orders are
supposed to be disobeyed or the
perpetrator can be held accountable just
like that person giving the order and in
fact there's historical precedent from
this you can go back to World War Two
and the I was just following orders
defense is one that is not valid so I I
don't know we're now getting sort of
it's hugely depressing that we're even
getting into this conversation to this
degree but this is the world in
20 under Donald Trump we have an
opportunity to end at least part of it
just ten months from now I hope that we
will take that opportunity we'll get a
little bit later in the program to the
spineless Republicans fourteen of whom
could end this national tragedy and are
choosing not to do that but first let's
talk about Democrats trying anyway to
control Donald Trump on Iran